Good morning YouTube. Professor Jang
here coming to you from a beautiful
Toronto
morning. So um two big news to report.
The first big news is that there's
chatter now that the Israelis will
resume air strikes against Iran very
very shortly. And this comes after
Netanyahu's visit to Washington last
week where he presumably received
permission to do so from the Trump
administration.
Second big news is that NATO will resume
weapon shipments to Ukraine.
Trump has given Putin a 50 50-day
ultimatum to end this war in Ukraine or
else Trump will be really really angry
at him.
I understand that there are many who are
disappointed that Trump has not been
able
to end this war in Ukraine in one day as
he promised um during the campaign.
But if you've been an avid follower of
this channel, then you will know that
this was entirely expected. We can only
expect this war in Ukraine to expand. We
can only expect uh the Middle East
conflict to escalate. So today I want to
focus on the war in Ukraine. I want to
talk about Putin specifically
from a game perspective. This war in
Ukraine is very strange because American
strategy, American policy, American
tactics, they've all been
self-defeating. I'll give you three
examples. The first example is
um how aggressive America uh Ukrainian
strategy and military doctrine has been.
Second is um American sanctions against
Russia and the third example is the
blowing up of the Nordstream pipeline.
All three of these policies have been
defeling.
So to understand why, we're going to use
counterfactual. We're going to use game
theory counterfactual and compare it to
what actually happened. So let's start
with Ukrainian military strategy
um against Russia.
The counterfactual is this. The
counterfactual is that America chose not
to intervene.
NATO is not involved and Ukrainians are
left to fight the Russians by
themselves.
Well,
in this in this situation, the Russians
are very quickly in about 3 to six
months, they're able to bowdo their way
throughout eastern Ukraine. And in about
6 months time, they're able to encircle
Odessa. And if they capture Odessa, then
the entire eastern Ukraine region is now
under Russian control. The problem
though is that the Russians are
overextended
and what Russians are not very good at
is organization
and logistics and planning. And so what
the Ukrainians are able to do is they're
able to launch probing attacks against
Russian front lines that are very
effective. They're also able to employ
hidden run gerilla tactics behind the
lines to disrupt the flow of uh Russian
uh supplies. And after 6 months,
the Russian soldiers in Ukraine, they're
heavily demoralized because they don't
have enough to eat. Um there's really no
strategy moving forward. They're kind of
stuck where they are.
At first, the Russian people were in
favor of this war. there's patriotic
zeal but after six months
um they sour
um against this war and popular opinion
turns against Putin and now it's very
hard for Putin to sustain this war
there's no strategy moving forward the
Russian people don't really see the
point in this war um the Russian
military is heavily overextended in
Ukraine and in this instance
um
Ukraine will probably win this war. So
that's a counterfactual. If America did
not intervene in this war,
what happened in reality is that Ukraine
chose to fight for every inch of
territory. And because it did that, it
played to Russia's ultimate strength,
which is defensive artillery warfare.
It's the best in the world at that.
And um because the Ukrainians
kept on attacking
uh the Russian military, the Russian
military was forced to constantly adapt
and to be flexible and to be resilient.
Um so quickly it quickly learned how to
use drone warfare to its advantage. So,
another way of saying this is that by
constantly being on the offensive, by
fighting for every inch of territory,
the Ukrainian military trained the
Russian military on how to be a modern
military capable of fighting a modern
military campaign, spec specifically
using drone warfare.
Um and the result of this is that
Russia now has battlefield dominance. It
basically controls
um most of
eastern Ukraine, the Donbas region.
And the Ukrainian military
because of its relentless aggression
against the Russian military, it's
really now short on manpower. And the
morale in uh the military
is very low. And what's been amazing
about this campaign is the Ukrainians
haven't really learned battlefield
lessons. They really didn't adapt to how
the Russians were adapting. And this
sort of suggests that the entire
military campaign was being run out of
Brussels or Washington DC, but it's
certainly not being run by the
Ukrainians. And because of this, the
Ukrainians have really lost the war. So
that's the first example of where
uh American strategy in Ukraine has been
self-defeating. Second example um are
these American sanctions against Russia,
specifically targeting
Russian business people with close ties
to the um Putin regime, which is
basically every single business person
in Russia.
Um the counterfactual is
America does not impose sanctions.
Well, as this war runs its course, the
biggest opposition
to Putin
um is the oligarchal elite, these
business people who see their trade um
their industry suffer because of this
war and they start to organize
subtle
quiet underground resistance against uh
Putin. Basically, they engage in forms
of economic sabotage.
Putin and the business elite have always
had an uneasy relationship.
Um, but the fact that the
Americans targeted the business elite,
70 of the 200 top business people in
Russia were hit with sanctions. Then
what that did ultimately was unify the
business elite around Putin. They didn't
have an option there. If they in a ideal
world, they would prefer to maintain
close relationships with the western
world because that's where they send
their wealth and their children and
that's where they like to have their
second homes.
And we know this because of what's
happening in China. So there is a trade
war between United States and China, but
this is a general trade war that's
targeting the Chinese economy. It's not
targeting specific individuals
um in China. And as a result of this,
what's happened is
that the business elite have unified
against Ciinping and this has made
governance hard for Cing Ping. So the
example is an ideal world where Cinping
was in control, he would like the
military to start invasion plans against
Taiwan.
But that's not h but that's not what's
happening. It seems as though the uh
Chinese regime, it's in sort of
governance deadlock. He can't really
govern. Um we haven't heard that much
news from China. And there's always
these rumors that Senping is on his way
out. Now, these rumors are completely
false. They're fabricated. But it shows
you that he's not as powerful as people
like to believe. So when it comes to
China, it seems that American policy has
been calibrated in a way to achieve
long-term American interests. That's not
been true in Russia. The sanctions
against
um Putin's Putin's regime and the
oligarchical interest in Russia has
unified the Russian elite. Much more
problematic is that the western
financial system has frozen about $300
billion dollars in Russian assets.
That's essentially just stealing and
that um basically undermines the
credibility
of the western financial system and
ultimately it undermines the credibility
of the US dollar which is a source of
American imperial power. And so that's
been very self-defeating.
The third example I want to look at is
the blowing up of the Northstream
pipeline. Everybody knows the Americans
blew that up. And because it blew it up,
it's really caused the German economy,
which was dependent on cheap uh Russian
gas, it's caused the economy to crater.
So the kind of factual is the Americans
didn't do this. The Americans didn't
blow up the Northream pipeline. Well,
over time as this war in Ukraine um
continues, the German people would have
been very angry at Russia. In response,
there would been political pressure to
um impose sanctions on Russia. And so
the Germans would have stopped buying
Russian gas naturally and they would
start buying American uh oil naturally.
But and the German economy would have
created because of this. But at that
point, the German people would have
blamed Putin for their economic misery.
Instead, by blowing up the Nordstream
pipeline, the German people now all know
that they're suffering the economic
misery. It's all because of the
Americans. Okay? So, the blame now rests
on the Americans. And this is long-term
problematic because
there's only one force that can possibly
defeat the the Anglo-American Empire and
that's a and that is a alliance between
Germany and Russia and that's ultimately
what Putin wants. And so by blowing up
the Northstream pipeline, America has
basically
um unleashed these structural forces
that will culminate in a possible
alliance between Germany and Russia and
that would ultimately destroy the
Anglo-American hijgemoni in the world.
So these are three examples of um
American policies that are
self-defeating.
And again from a game third perspective,
this is this is
strange. And again, when it comes when
it comes to China, American policy is
far more calibrated. It's far more
strategic. Um it's far more able to
achieve long-term American interests. So
the mystery, the paradox that we're
looking at today is
why
is it that when it comes to Russia,
American policy is so self-defeating?
It's almost as though Putin has spies
implanted within the Western Imperial
apparatus.
Um,
it's very very strange.
The second question I want to look at
today is
where exactly did Putin come from? How
is it that that this nobody
um this man who came from a lower middle
class family in St. Petersburg and he
was an unknown entity for the for the
first um 30 years of his life. How did
he suddenly become the most powerful man
in Russia? So that's the second big
question I want to look at today. The
third big question is where is this all
going? What does Putin want? Why did he
invade Ukraine? Okay, so those are the
three big questions we're looking at
today. And I'll be very honest with you,
these three questions are unanswerable.
Okay, I don't know why. I don't know the
answers to any of these three questions.
And quite honestly, we'll never know
because there's not enough information
uh to work with.
So, what I'm going to do today is I'm
going to present a hypothesis.
And there's going to be a lot of
problems with this hypothesis. But the
good thing is that with any hypothesis,
there is embedded in it in a prediction
model. So I'm I'm I'm going to explain
to you the hypothesis and then from the
hypothesis I'm going to conjecture
certain predictions that this hypothesis
model entails and these predictions will
tell us if the hypothesis model is
correct or not. Okay. So that's what
we're going to do today. All right. So
let me present to you my hypothesis
to the three questions.
Um why is Putin winning the war Ukraine?
Where did he come from? What does he
want? Okay, so I'm going to start off
with a couple of biographical details
about Putin. And remember, um, what's
really important is we're getting these
details from the mouth of Putin himself.
So, it's possible these details are
fabricated. It's possible they're
embellished. Um,
but let's just look at these two
details. The first detail I want to look
at is Putin tell told the New York Times
in interview that his grandfather
Spirrodon Putin was the personal cook to
both Vladimir Put sorry Vladimir Lennon
as well as Joseph Stalin. Okay, that's
the first detail I want to look at.
Second detail I want to look at is and
again uh Putin told this to reporters in
an interview. His mother was a devout
Christian who secretly baptized him and
even today he wears the baptismal cross
um to show his devotion to his mother
and to his faith and to his country. So
um what do these two details tell us?
And again remember what's really
important is these two bio bical details
could be completely fabricated. Okay.
All right. But let's assume that there
is truth to these um details.
Spiritan Putin, Putin Putin's
grandfather was the personal cook to
both Lenin and Salin. Well, what this
tells us is that he was a very powerful
person because he had access to the most
powerful people in
uh Russia. And if you're powerful, uh,
then you can start to do favors for
other people. You can promote their
careers. You can also save their lives.
And as a result,
a lot of people high up in the Soviet
bureaucracy,
the nomenclature,
uh, they a lot of favors to Putin's
grandfather. Okay, that's the first
thing. Second thing is
because he was a personal cook to the
most powerful people in the Soviet
Union, it meant that he was extremely
trusted. Um, he was probably part of the
KGB, a very high official within the KGB
and also the KGB was probably spying on
him, his family, and all his friends.
And they found nothing wrong with this
guy. uh Spiran Putin died of old age. He
he died when was 86 when Putin was 13
years old. And he was never purged. He
was never arrested. He was never
um suspected of anything. Okay? So this
man clearly was humble. He had no
ambitions and he was selfless. He was
dedicated to his leaders, preparing good
meals for his leaders. And um that
suggests to me that he was religious.
And again, it was very common for
Russians of his generation, of his
background to be Orthodox Christian.
And so he was probably
um religious and he was probably a
devout orthodox Christian. Okay, that's
second thing that we must know about
him. The third thing that I suspect is
that he really loved and admire Lenin
and Stalin, especially Stalin because
remember in World War II Hitler invaded
the Soviet Union. It really seemed the
end of days. Um 27 million Soviet
citizens died in this war. And
um for a Russian
to have won this war, you you had to
believe that it was divine intervention
and you had to believe that Stalin
really was the Messiah.
Um and what's important is
Stalin was able to win this war because
of his reproachment with the Orthodox
Church. Starting with Lenin, there was
massive persecution
of the Orthodox church because Lenin,
Trosky, they were all atheist, Marxist
intellectuals who believe that it was
Orthodox Christianity that kept uh
Russia feudal, primitive, backward.
Stalin is different because Stalin was
not a Marxist intellectual.
He never went to university like Lenin
and Trosky.
Um in fact he was poor. His father was
an abusive alcoholic. His mother though
was a devout Christian who sent her son
to seminary in order to become an
Orthodox priest.
And so Salin didn't grow up in the
Marxist tradition. He grew up in the
Orthodox tradition. And that's probably
why um he got along much better with the
Orthodox Church than he did with these
marchers intellectuals
whom he ultimately purged and um um
killed.
So during World War II, Stalin had to
engage the people. He had to excite
them. And so he relied on the Orthodox
Church to stir up these ethnic religious
sentiments, these nationalistic
sentiments in order to unite the people
against the Nazis. And for the Orthodox
Church, this really was a holy war. This
was a war between the third Rome, which
is Moscow. Um, in the Orthodox
tradition, Moscow is considered the
third Rome. Um the sec second Rome of
course was Consenapole which fell to
Ottoman Turks in for 1453.
And so this um war was really the
ultimate struggle between true Christian
civilization which is Soviet Union and
uh the antichrist which was Nazi
Germany.
And the Orthodox church then had to see
Stalin as messiah, as as the chosen one
who would lead them to ultimate victory
against uh the Nazis, who would redeem
Russian civilization from the evil
communism and who would restore the
Bison Empire.
But before
uh Stalin could restore the Bison
Empire, he died. Some believe
that his colleagues who are afraid of
him, they poison him. But in the
Orthodox tradition, that just means that
he truly is Messiah. Because remember,
Jesus had to die before we could be
redeemed. And Jesus had to die before
the world could truly believe in him.
And because he died, there's now a
promise that he would eventually return
and save the world, the second coming.
So after Salin died, we can imagine that
there were many people within the
Orthodox Church and also within elite
Soviet politics that believed that S
would ultimately return
to lead the lead Russian civilization
into ultimate victory against the
antichrist. and he would ultimately
restore the Baian Empire which is the
destiny of Moscow.
So why is this important? It's important
because these ideas spirit Putin would
um tell his grandson Vladimir Putin.
Spiritan Putin would also introduce
Putin to um this elite nexus of power
um within the Orthodox church and within
uh the Soviet hierarchy so that Putin
was well known to powerful people
and ultimately
Spiritin Putin would come to believe
that his grandson it's possible this
um very precocious young man. It is
possible that he could be the second
coming of Stalin. Okay. And so
this helps us helps us understand and
answer the second question which is how
did um Putin come into power? And the
reason is that he was well known to a
secret faction of the Orthodox Church
and the KGB.
And he was slowly nurtured over time.
And when the time was appropriate at the
fall of the Soviet Union, after
basically um the the increasing
unpopularity of the Elson regime, they
thought now is perfect time to put Putin
into power.
Um this also helps us explain the third
question which is what Putin
wants and Putin wants to be the second
coming of Stalin. He wants to finish the
mission that Stalin could not finish,
which is the restoration
of the Bison Empire.
And so how will this be accomplished?
Well, within the Orthodox esquetological
tradition, there's a prophecy. And this
prophecy is attributed most famously to
uh a Greek Orthodox monk uh named Pacios
of Mount Anthos. There's controversy as
to whether or not he actually said this
prophecy, but it's most commonly
attributed to him. And that's what the
Russian narrative is. And the prophecy
goes like this.
Russia and Turkey are destined to go to
war against each other right now. Um,
President Aragon of Turkey, he's a very
sly political operator. He's able to
balance competing factions within his
government, but he's also able to
compete to sorry, he's also able to
balance competing forces
in geopolitics, specifically Russia and
NATO. Turkey is a member of NATO, but
Turkey remains a close relationship with
Russia.
But after he passes from Msine, after he
falls in power, then the new government
will become very pro-NATO.
And at that point, Turkey will start
aggressive policies against Russia, like
for example, closing off the Bosphorus
um
and allowing NATO warships to enter the
Black Sea, which will force Russia to
invade Turkey. Um Russia will destroy
Turkey in a matter of days because
remember Russia is a nuclear uh
superpower
and then Russia will hand Turkey
Caranopole back to the Greeks and this
will restore the Basian Empire. the Haga
Sophia, the main cathedral in Consipole,
which was the seat for many centuries,
um the seat of the Orthodox world
that will be restored as an Orthodox
church. It will be cleansed of it, of
its Islamic um pollution, and this will
unify the Orthodox world um around
Russia and around Putin. Okay? And
that's the prophecy.
And when I heard about this prophecy
online and and what I'll do is I'll link
YouTube I'll link um YouTube videos
describing this prophecy in the in the
description. It's very important that
you yourself um understand this
prophecy.
When I um
when I first encountered this prophecy,
I thought it was very strange because it
didn't really sound like a prophecy. It
sounded more like a plan. So, I won't be
surprised if the truth is that Russian
intelligence implanted this prophecy
among Orthodox monks because remember
there's always been a close relationship
between Russian intelligence and the
Orthodox Church
and
um
and and and so what's the plan? The plan
is to cause a war between Russia and
Turkey which will allow Russia to
reclaim Constantinopole and then it
would uh unite the Orthodox world.
So that's prophecy. So how would this
plan come into being? Well, what's
interesting is if you look at the
trajectory of the war in Ukraine right
now, it seems that this plan, this
prophecy will happen naturally because
the next phase of this war is the
Russian encircumment of Odessa. If
Russians are able to take Odessa,
Ukraine is finished because Russia will
be able to control the entire coastline
which allows them to control uh trade
and logistics in the Black Sea.
And once Russia controls Eastern
Ukraine, the war is over because Eastern
Ukraine is the agricultural and
industrial heartland
of Ukraine. Russian UK Russ western
Ukraine will become a welfare state for
the European Union and Putin is very
happy to have that happen.
This means that NATO will make its last
stand in Odessa. Right now a lot of
preparations are being made to reinforce
Odessa and
um this is great for Putin because once
the Russians are have been able to
encircle Odessa, it becomes a death trap
for NATO.
um NATO will send in a lot of soldiers
and they're all just going to die there
and this is going to cause a lot of
popular resentment
um back in France, in Britain, in Poland
and this will probably cause
a civil war in these nations. Remember
these nations are already on the brink
of civil war
and what's more important is that
eventually Turkey will be brought into
this war because it is a NATO ally and
as a result this gives Putin the
opportunity to confront Turkey. And
again what's really important for us to
understand is that
Russia does not have to defeat Turkey on
the battlefield. It doesn't even have to
defeat France or Britain. All Russia has
to do is draw this war out. And this war
will become increasingly unpopular in
Turkey, in Britain, in France, which
leads to civil discontent, which leads
to political chaos. And eventually these
nations will collapse um and implode
economically and politically. And when
that happens, Russia will be um
victorious.
And so that's Putin's plan moving
forward to make Odessa into the final
battle between NATO and Russia, which
will culminate in the implosion, the
blog implosion of Turkey, which will
allow for Russia to take over Turkey. In
fact, the Turkish people might even
invite Putin and the Russians into
into Turkey, thus fulfilling the
prophecy and thus proving
that um Putin is in fact the Messiah and
the second coming of Joseph Stalin. The
best evidence for this is again that the
biographic detail that Putin revealed to
journalists that his mother was a devout
Christian uh who baptized Putin
secretly.
This detail is important because it's a
it it's a dog whistle to all those
orthodox fanatics and extreme Russians
out there that in fact Putin and Stalin
have a lot of similarities. Um in fact
they're probably the same person because
remember son himself his mother was a
devout Christian um who sent him to
seminary uh school.
So um
that explains the second idea. Okay,
that helps us answer second question
which is what does Putin want? Putin
wants to restore the bison empire. He
wants to unify the Orthodox world and he
wants to retake Constantinopole from the
Turks and this war in Ukraine is the
perfect platform. It's a perfect um
mechanism for him to achieve the um his
ambitions. And this leads us to the
first question which is how is Putin
able to do all this? How is Putin able
to be to be able to control history like
this? Uh Frederick Hegel would call
Putin the world historical figure and
Frederick Nichi would call Putin the
ubbermans, the superman, the overman,
the man who was able to step outside of
history to control history and achieve
um his book ambitions and by doing so
forever change the course of human
history. How is he the Uber mates? Okay,
so to answer this question and again I
don't know the answer. Okay, so here I'm
only speculating. To answer this
question, what's really important for us
to understand is the conflict between
the Orthodox Christian world and Western
civilization.
for Orthodox
um Christians, they really see Western
civilization as a manifestation of the
Antichrist.
Because Western civilization, the three
pillars of Western civilization are
capitalism, science, and liberalism.
Liberalism is a cult of the individual,
the belief in hiddenism, the belief that
the pursuit of individual pleasure is
what matters most in life. Science is a
rejection of God and the worship of the
material world. Capitalism is pure
greed, pure selfishness. So for Orthodox
Christians, resilization means a
rejection of God, of faith, of
tradition, which is what the Orthodox
tradition represents.
And so for Orthodox Christians, this is
a war of civilization, a struggle of
civilizations. And only one can survive.
Only the western viewpoint can survive
or the Orthodox viewpoint can survive.
And um Orthodox Christians are
determined
to uh win this war because if they don't
win this war, then the world the world
um is
>> hopeless. The world is pointless. And
Putin himself has said this in a speech.
Okay. So,
um
it seems as though Western civilization
is much more powerful than Orthodox
civilization, right? Western
civilization, Western Europe, America,
it's much more advanced economically,
scientifically, technologically. It has
a greater population. It has more
resources. It has more wealth.
But the orthox Christians believe that
God is with them. God communicates with
them and God is
planning on the destruction of the of
the Western civilization and the
Orthodox Christians are only the tool of
God to achieve this. If you look at
current events, then there's a lot of
justification for this.
But um let me explain this in a
different way. Okay. So
I believe and a lot of people will
believe that there is
um an underlying consciousness to the
universe.
Hegel calls this the gist. Uh Carl Young
call calls this the collective
unconscious
because because we have thoughts, right?
Well, the question then is where do our
thoughts come from and where do they go?
So let's assume that there is a um a
collective
unconscious to the universe and we can
call this force God.
Well, if that's the case, then we're
able to communicate with this collective
unconscious.
Um as long as you believe it exists, as
long as you make the effort to embrace
this collective unconscious, as long as
as long as you have faith in God. The
problem with western civilization is it
denies exist existence of God. It denies
the existence of this collective
unconscious because of its embrace of
materialism. And as a result, it's lost
its connection with this collective
unconscious. But because the Orthodox
tradition, it's much more mystical. It's
it's focused much more on miracles. It's
much more focused on faith. Then there
are certain mystics within the Orthodox
tradition who are capable of
communicating with this collective
unconscious.
And if you're capable of collective of
if you're capable communicating with
this collective unconscious, then you're
also capable of
influencing in a certain way that allows
you to achieve outcomes that you desire.
Okay? And this helps us understand how
Putin is able to control the battlefield
in Ukraine, how he's able to man
manipulate the Americans into policies
that are self-defeating.
And it ultimately gives us a sense that
Putin will actually ultimately win out
in the end because he could be the Uber
Muts. Okay, so that's the hypothesis. Um
the hypothesis is
that during the time of Stalin, a secret
nexus of power between the Orthodox
Church and the KGB came into being and
they were determined to achieve the
third Rome prophecy and restore the Bian
empire. They thought that Stalin could
help them achieve this. But after his
death, they had to await the second
coming of Stalin. And so they were
looking for possible candidates.
Finally, they settled on Putin and they
elevated him into into supreme power.
They support him ever since.
And now with this war in Ukraine, they
see the opportunity to destroy Western
civilization and res and create the
third world and restore the Bitan
Empire. Okay, that's the plan. That's
the hypothesis. Now with this
hypothesis, we can make three
predictions based on this hypothesis
that will tell us if this hypothesis is
correct or not. So the first prediction
of course is the war in Ukraine will
shift to Odessa. That's where the final
battle between NATO and Russia will take
place. Turkey will be brought into this
war. Once Turkey ended this war, it will
become extremely unpopular within
Turkey, which will lead to the implosion
of the Turkish government and a
revolution which would allow Russia to
come in easily to control Turkey. Okay,
so Odess is the first big big
prediction. The second big prediction is
there'll be a falling out between China
and Russia. Because if this hypothesis
is correct and Russia is fighting a war
for civilization, for the soul of
humanity,
um it's fighting a war for God,
then the true enemy is western
civilization, but it's also China
because China is even more even more of
a godless,
valueless, materialistic society than
Western civilization. At the very least,
United States, uh, Britain, France, they
profess to be Christian. But, uh, China,
it is decidedly communist, atheist, and
it's proudly so. So, Russia has contempt
for China and ultimately sees China as
an enemy. Eventually, they'll be falling
out. Okay? And we'll see this happen
very quickly. And the third prediction
is that Russia will defend Iran. It
cannot afford for Iran to fall. Not only
for geopolitical reasons, but because in
this cosmology,
>> in this war uh between Russian
civilization and Russian civilization,
Iran is an important ally for Russian
civilization because they're both both
Russia and Iran are fighting to bring
God back to humanity. Okay, so those are
the three big predictions. if they of
all three predictions happen where um
the war in Ukraine shifts to this final
catismic struggle in Odessa, where
Russia and China are falling out and
where um
Russia comes to the aid of Iran, then we
will have strong evidence that my
hypothesis is correct and in fact Putin
does see himself as the second coming of
Stalin.
Okay. So, um
that's it. Um what I will do in my next
video is connect all the desperate
pieces together
and try to predict what will happen
around the world next 5 to 10 years.
Quick announcement. I'm taking a break
uh next week. I'm taking my kids um
camping. It's something that that we've
been planning for a long time. So,
unfortunately, I won't be able to do a a
video next week, but I will be back the
week after. Um, also,
tomorrow from 8 to 10:00 p.m., uh, East
Eastern Standard Time, I'll be doing a
Discord live stream. Um, where I will I
can help you elaborate or explain
certain issues. um um that you've been
struggling with over the course of these
uh videos.
Um one last announcement is last week I
announced that I have a buy me a coffee
account and the support has been
overwhelming. So, thank you so much for
supporting my my work. It's really
helpful. But again, um don't feel any
pressure to support me. If you have the
means, please do so. uh it's really
helpful. I really appreciate it. But
don't feel any pressure to do so. I see
my mission as trying to educate as many
people as possible. Um, I'm trying to
help you understand the the world. And I
I understand that many of you might be
confused or they might disagree with
what I'm saying. But what's really
important is this is a learning process
and we're both trying to develop
theories and hypotheses and anecdotal
models to better understand the world.
So, it's a process and there are a lot
of things in which I'm I'm going to be
wrong. But what's really important is
there are predictions in place and if
these predictions happen then that's
good reason to think that the analytical
model I'm proposing is correct. They
don't happen then we'll just go back and
change the analyical model. Okay. So
this is a um process in which we're all
trying to learn together. So that's it.
Um thank you for listening to this video
and I will see everyone next time.